great blood drive is underway right now
the American Red Cross Blood mobile is
in the 8 News Now parking lot dozens of
people including some of our employees
giving blood at this moment Candace
Charles joining us live from that great
blood drive with the impact Candace
looks like you're next up
yes I have rolled up my sleeve and I'm
ready to go now the national volunteer
month but giving blood is actually not
as common in fact only about three
percent of people that can donate blood
do so the blood Mobility is here in our
parking lot to make it easy for you and
have Rachel Flanagan here with me from
the American Red Cross Southern Nevada
tell us a little bit about where this
blood will go in the whole health
absolutely so when it first gets drawn
you'll see it on your blood Journey
Through the blood app that we have it'll
go up to Salt Lake and it'll get
processed and then it gets Diversified
from there a lot of the time it does
come back down to the valley because we
distribute to 10 or more area hospitals
absolutely I know that it is needed
right now and this is simple enough
right I'm already in the chair tell us a
little bit about the process okay so
what they do is they start out in the
back here and they're going to do a
medical history make sure that
everything's okay for you to be able to
donate blood they're going to bring you
over here ask you a couple of quick
questions and then they're going to do
that fun hunt for the vein yes always
good oh absolutely and I have to tell
you it's like getting kissed by a kitten
when you get that needle put in you know
I'm kidding but it doesn't hurt nearly
as bad as people think they get that
needle in and then you're here for about
15 or so minutes and then you're out the
door the whole process takes less than
an hour okay simple and quick enough
thank you Rachel for all you in the
community we appreciate you and for
joining us look at these cute little
shirts you guys get with this as well
now I do know the list is all full
already for today but the blood Mobility
will be will be in the front if you guys
want to come by give support it'll be
running until six we'll be showing you a
little bit more on our later shows but
for now live from the this now parking
lot I'm Candace Charles Amy's now